quoi de mieux pour expliquer un tel
phénomène que de faire appel au
directeur du planétarium de montréal à
l'aide de peluches qui représente les
astres tout devient simple on à la terre
ici et là l'une va est en orbite autour
de la terre
et lorsque la lune passe dans l'ombre de
la terre la lune va s'éclipser en fait
l'alignement du soleil de la terre et de
la lune était parfait
les éclipses de lune c'est relativement
fréquents la dernière s'est produite au
début de l'année en janvier 2018
mais la particularité de celle ci c'est
que la phase dite de totalité de
l'éclipsé a duré 1h43
ce qui en fait la plus longue du 21e
siècle ceci non parce que simplement la
lune est un petit peu plus loin sur son
orbite l'orbité de la lune n'est pas
tout à fait circulaire en fait mais
plutôt elliptique
il y a deux points importants le point
qu'on appelle l'apogée et le point qu'on
appelle le périgée et le périgée c'est
pour dépérissent lui dire près de la
terre apogée c'est à dire loin de la
terre et la lune est à cet endroit là en
fait l'apogée à son point le plus loin
l'astre lunaire se trouvait à 400 6222
kilomètres de distance ce qui explique
qu'il ait mis autant de temps à
contourner notre planète bleue pour
sortir de son ombre
malheureusement le phénomène n'était pas
visible en amérique du nord dans sa
totalité on parle vraiment de l'europe
vraiment de l'est delà de l'asie de
l'afrique
ailleurs dans le monde les gens se sont
rassemblés pour observer le phénomène
mais par endroit les nuages ont masqué
le spectacle la saison de la mousson
raconte cette dame les nuages on cacher
la vue alors nous étions très déçus
à défaut de le voir sur le terrain de
nombreux curieux ont pu au moins
observer le spectacle céleste sur leur
écran
ici julie aimant radio canada montréal
[Musique]